Raj and welcome to the mat
of intelligence.
For the next three months.
We're going to take a journey through
the most important math concepts.
That underlying machine learning.
That means all the concepts you need
from the great disciplines of Calculus,
linear Algebra,
probability theory and statistics.
The prerequisites are knowing
basic python syntax and Algebra.
Every single algorithm we code will be
done without using any popular machine
learning library because the point of
this course is to help you build a solid
mathematical intuition around building
algorithms that can learn from data.
I mean,
let's face it,
you could just use a black
box API for all this stuff,
but if you have the intuition,
you'll know exactly which algorithm to
use for the job or even custom make your
own from scratch.
As humans,
we are constantly receiving
data through our five senses.
Then somehow we've got to make sense of
all of this chaotic input so that we can
survive.
Thanks to the evolutionary process.
We've developed brains
capable of doing this.
We've got the most precious resource
in the universe. Intelligence,
the ability to learn and apply knowledge.
One way to measure our intelligence
against the rest of the animal kingdom is
using a ladder.
Arts is indeed the most generalized
type of intelligence capable of being
applied to the widest variety of tasks,
but that doesn't mean that we are
necessarily the best kind of intelligence.
In the 1960s a primate researcher
named Dr Jane Goodall concluded that
chimpanzees had been living in the
forest for hundreds of thousands of years
without overpopulating or
destroying their environment at all.
Orca is have the ability to sleep with
one hemisphere of their brain at a time,
which allows them to recuperate while
being aware of their surroundings.
In some ways,
animals are more intelligent than us.
Intelligence consists of many dimensions.
Think of it like a multidimensional
space of possibility when building AI,
the human brain is a great roadmap.
After all,
neural networks have achieved state of
the art performance in countless tasks,
but it's not the only roadmap.
There are many possible
types of intelligence out
there that we can and will
create.
Some will seem familiar to us and some
very alien thinking in a way we've never
done before.
Like when Alpha go played move 37 even
the best go players in the world were
stunned at the move.
It went against everything we've
learned about the game from millennia of
practice,
but it turned out to be an objectively
better strategy that led to its win.
The many different types of
intelligence or like symphonies,
each comprising of different instruments
and these instruments very not just
their names dynamics,
but in their pitch and
tempo and color and melody.
The amount of data we're generating
is growing really fast. No,
I mean really,
really fast.
In the time since you started watching
this video and enough data was generated
for you to spend an entire
lifetime analyzing and only
0.5% of all data ever is
creating intelligence
isn't just a nice to have.
It's a necessity put in the right hands.
It will help us solve problems we never
dreamed could be possible to solve.
So where do we start?
At its core,
machine learning is all about
mathematical optimization.
This is a way of thinking.
Every single problem can be broken
down into an optimization problem.
Once we have some dataset
that acts as our input,
we'll build a model that uses that
data to optimize for an objective,
a goal that we want to reach and the
way it does this is by minimizing some
error value that we defined.
One example problem could
be what should I wear today?
I could frame this as optimizing for
stylishness. Instead of say comfort,
then define an error that
I want to minimize as the
amount of ratings a group of
people give me that are negative or even
what's the best design for my Ios apps
home page.
Rather than hard coding.
In some elements I could find a Dataset
of APP designs and their ratings from
users. If I want to optimize for a
design that would be the highest rated.
I would learn the mapping between
design styles and ratings.
This is the way every single layer of
the stack will be built in the future.
Sometimes our data is labeled,
sometimes it isn't.
There are different techniques we can
use to find patterns in this data.
And sometimes optimizing
for an objective can happen,
not through the frame
of pattern recognition,
but through the exploration
of many possibilities and
seeing what works and what
doesn't. There are many ways that
we can frame the learning process.
But the easiest way to learn,
it's when we use labeled data,
mathematically speaking,
we have some input.
There's a domain x where every point
of x has features that we observed.
Then we have a label set y.
So the data consists of a set of labeled
examples that we can denote this way.
The output then would be a prediction
rule. So given a new x value,
what it's associated, why value,
we've got to learn this mapping,
which is an unknown distribution
over x to be able to answer this.
So we have to measure some error function
that acts as a performance metric.
So what we do is choose from a number
of possible models to represent this
function well.
Initially set some parameter values to
represent the mapping and we'd evaluate
the initial results, measured
the error, update the parameters.
And repeat this process,
optimizing the model again and again
until it fully learns the mapping.
Was it convex or concave functions
that were easier to optimize?
I think convex. I really hope my
lab partners advocate optimization.
I guess I should be thankful.
Not many data scientists get a grant
from cern to detect the Higgs Boson.
What was her name again?
Oh, Luis. I think. Yeah, she
did win an award from ICML.
I wonder if she's cute.
That doesn't matter.
I am not going to mix business
and pleasure. Not this time.
Suppose I've got a bunch of data points.
These are just data points like what
apple probably trained Siri on there.
All x y value pairs were x represents
the distance a person bikes and why
represents the amount
of calories they lost.
We can just plot them on a graph like so.
We want to be able to predict the
calories lost for a new person,
even their biking distance.
How should we do this? Well,
we could try to draw a line that
it's through all the data points,
but it seems like our points are too
spaced out for a straight line to pass
through all of them so we can settle
for drawing the line of best fit a line
that goes through as many
data points as possible.
Algebra tells us that the equation for
a straight line is of the form y equals
mx plus B where m represents the
slope or steepness of the line and be
represents.
It's why access intercept points.
We want to find the optimal values
for B and m such that the line,
it's as many points as possible.
Given any new x value,
we can plug it into our equation and
it'll help put the most likely why value
our error metric can be a measure of
closeness, which we can define like this.
So let's start off with a random B and
m value and plot this line for every
single data point we have. Let's
calculate it's associated. Why value?
Then we'll subtract the actual why value
from it to measure the distance between
the two. We'll want to square this
error to make our next steps easier.
Once we sum all of these values, we get
a single value that represents our error.
Given that line we just drew. Now,
if we did this process repeatedly,
say 1,337 times for a bunch of
different randomly drawn lines,
we could create a three d graph that
shows the air value for every associated B
and m value.
Notice how there is a valley in this
graph at the bottom of this valley,
the error is at its smallest and so the
associated bnm values would be the line
of best fit,
where the distance between all our
data points and our line would be the
smallest, but how do we find it? Well,
we'll need to try out a bunch of different
lines to create this three d graph,
but rather than just randomly drawing
lines over and over again with no signal,
what if we could do it in a more efficient
way such that each successive we draw
brings us closer and closer to the bottom
of this valley. We need a direction,
a way to descend this valley.
What hip for a given function,
we could find the slope
of it at a given point.
Then that slope would point in a certain
direction towards the Minima of the
graph and when we redraw our
lines over and over again,
we could do so using the
slope as our compass,
as our guide on how best to redraw
towards the minima until our slope
approaches zero. In Calculus,
we call this slope the
derivative of a function.
Since we are updating to value B, and, m,
we want to calculate the derivative
with respect to both of them,
the partial derivative,
the partial derivative with respect to
a variable means that we calculate the
derivative of that variable
while ignoring the others,
so it will compute the partial
derivative with respect to B.
Then the partial derivative
with respect to em. To do this,
we use the power rule.
We multiply the exponent by
the Coefficient and subtract
one from the exponent.
Once we have these two values,
we can update both of these parameters
from our function by subtracting them
from our existing DNM values and we
just keep doing that for a set number of
iterations that we predefined.
So this optimization technique that we
just performed is called gradient descent
and it's the most popular
one in machine learning.
So what do you need to remember
from this video? Three points.
The derivative is the slope
of a function at a given line.
The partial derivative is a slope
with respect to one variable.
In that function we can use them to
compose a gradient which points in the
direction of the local Minima of a
function and gradient descent is a very
popular optimization strategy in machine
learning that uses the gradient to do
this. The winter of last week's
coding challenge is typical hog.
He created an encryption algorithm that's
pretty complex written in c plus plus
that I've never heard of before.
Definitely check it out.
Links in the description.
Great Work Wizard
of the wick. Now it's your turn.
I've got a coding challenge for you.
Implement grading dissent on your own
on a different datasets that all provide
check checkup and get
hub link for details.
And the winner will be
announced in a week.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to memorize the power rule,
so thanks for watching.